im bündner schanfigg talweg der
pioniergeist und dieser geist wohnt in
schulhaus von gastiert hier ansetzen
darf lehrerin eva ketteritzsch zusammen
mit ihren schülern macht sie mit beim
digitalen sprachprojekt alb connect us
dollar
die idee ist einfach prima schüler aus
drei sprachregionen sollen sich
kennenlernen und in einer fremdsprache
miteinander reden lernen die
deutschsprachigen bündner üben
italienisch mit einer klasse aus dem
tessin
die tessiner wiederum sprechen wir den
kollegen aus dem wallis französisch und
die walliser verbessern ihre
deutschkenntnisse im kontakt mit den
spenden blut geht wo das wirklich reden
dass ich wär so ein aha effekt gefahren
der erstkontakt erfolg ganz zeitgemäß
per video-konferenz die verständigung
ist zwar direkter aber nicht unbedingt
einfacher wer eine fremdsprache lernt
holt die welt ins eigene haus das galt
schon immer
nur waren die methoden früher deutlich
weniger interaktiv
heute sollen schüler nicht nur mehr die
sprache lernen sondern das reden
miteinander über ganz alltägliches die
kleinen üben was sich die großen im
bundeshaus für die schweiz wünschen
kulturminister albers gilt als mister
sprachenvielfalt und setzt sich
dezidiert für den austausch der
verschiedenen sprachregionen 1
in der aktuellen kultur botschaft
formuliert er es so möglichst viele
jugendliche sollen einmal in ihrer
schulischen laufbahn an einem nationalen
austauschprojekt teilnehmen
in oberwald kanton wallis findet das
finale des sprach- lern- projekt stadt
ganz im sinne von bundesrat der sie
lernen sich die schüler nun endlich
persönlich kennen
doch klappt die verständigung jeder
pariert in einer fremdsprache
theoretisch eine hübsche idee nur die
welt ist ein globales dorf statt
französisch wird auf portugiesisch
ausgewichen
das hätte natürlich sofort merken
schreiben ist mit einer sprache nicht
wiederholen logsch füreinander und
schlussendlich ist diese art umgangen
dass in kontakt
es hat funktioniert weil es tessin und
graubünden sind sich ein kleines
bisschen hergekommen zur fremden sprache
gehören jetzt bekannte gesichter aber
können die bündner jetzt besser
italienisch
das italienisch also ich denke sie sind
in der lage im tal in der für ihre
bistümer räder mit überkommenen kontakte
und da nicht ergründen
eva kötteritzsch will auch beim nächsten
austausch mitmachen weil so
fremdsprachen lebendig werden und in
einer weise wie es kein schulbuch der
welt kann sondern eben nur das leben
selbst